the last two years have showed us
this truth in a profound way and they
demonstrate why alberta's government is
making such historic investments in
healthcare right now with alberta's
recovery plan that's our plan to build
the key infrastructure the schools roads
bridges and yes hospitals
that albertans need both today and in
the future
in fact just three days ago i was in red
deer to announce the largest single
infrastructure investment in central
alberta history the 1.8 billion dollar
investment to upgrade uh the red deer
hospital and expand capacity so that we
can never again repeat the kind of
stress that our system was under at the
peaks of kovid
so thank you all for being great
partners in alberta's health system
dedicated to keeping albertans
healthy and happy
now before we get to the
real business of the day the exciting
official grand opening of this
incredible new hospital in grand prairie
i want to take a moment uh to talk about
the easing of additional covet 19
restrictions across the province
starting on march the first
it seems fitting that we are here at a
hospital to talk about covid where so
many individual battles against that
disease have been fought
time and again
our health care system has been
stretched to its very limits its workers
physically and mentally exhausted our
facilities constantly readjusting their
spaces to accommodate yet more patients
and they continue to care for albertans
like the dedicated professionals that
they are fortunately all signs here and
across the world suggest that the worst
of covet 19 is behind us
the pressure on our health care system
is easing as hospitalizations due to
covet 19 are declining
on february the 8th when we announced
that alberta was moving to step one of
our path back to normal there were
1615 albertans in hospital with covet 19
and i i paused to say that uh that 40 of
those were incidental covet cases
as opposed to being treated for covid
yesterday that number of total covet
patients in our hospitals was down to
just under 1300 and that's a 20 decline
in just uh under three weeks
we've seen a further reduction in
alberta's intensive care units
where there are currently 88 people with
covet and that's down about 34
since we started opening on february the
8th
our seven day average of total
hospitalizations
of 1435
now
is down from an average of over 1600
from february 14th and the seven day
average for
intensive care occupancy has also
decreased significantly
to 103 down from 126 on february the
14th so all the numbers are going
in a very positive direction and the
best news when it comes to our hospitals
is that overall our rate of new
hospitalizations
due to covet 19 has dropped
significantly over the last month
in addition to declining numbers in our
hospitals
our daily cases and that's more of a
leading indicator continue to decline
quickly yesterday we saw an increase of
only 600 cases and that's down from a
peak
of 6 800 on january the 11th so a 90
decline in daily new cases since then we
recognize that due to changes in
our pcr testing regime that the the
number of active cases isn't now the
best metric but it's still an
encouraging sign especially when we look
at the positivity rate that's the
percentage of people getting a pcr test
that come out positive well on that
there is a continued
downward trend uh though there are
slight fluctuations of course from day
to day
so on that metric our our seven day
average
pcr testing positivity rate
is at
22.9 percent
when it was uh 29
just 10 days before
our active case rate continues to fall
the provincial active case rate per 100
000 people
well it's it's 240 now
and that's down from 472 last week in
addition
trending data from our waste water
surveillance and we do that in grand
prairie in about
17 other communities around the province
and that's an important leading
indicator well it shows that
transmission is falling or is stable in
almost every one of the 18 communities
where we do that testing
and when considering all of this
information together as a whole
there is no evidence at this point
that to suggest that our transition to
uh
normal is negatively affecting our
health care system
and in fact it appears that overall
transmission in the province continues
to decline hospitalizations continue to
decline and all of these positive trends
continue after schools were resumed in
classroom learning six weeks ago
and
three weeks after we lifted all
restrictions on kids including masking
for kids and lifted the restriction
exemption program on february 8th so
that's important because we needed to do
this carefully and prudently we didn't
want to rush into it we need to make
sure to take this one step at a time
to be sure
that our relaxation of these difficult
public health measures did not push us
back into an uptick in viral
transmission or hospitalizations and now
three weeks later we can say with
confidence that the numbers continue to
decline rapidly uh despite uh those
important measures we took three weeks
ago to open up
so i am very pleased to announce that
with these promising trends
we are in a position to safely move to
step two of our path back to normal and
remove the vast majority of remaining
public health measures in alberta
minister copying will provide additional
details but beginning on march the first
that is to say effective uh 11 59 pm on
february 28th good thing it's not a leap
year
we will end the provincial mass mandate
through
though masking
will still be required in higher risk
settings including public transit
alberta health services operated
facilities like this hospital
and continuing care settings nursing
homes across the province
we will also remove all capacity limits
for venues
we will end restrictions on interactive
activities
on liquor service and operating hours
for our bars and restaurants and
hospitality venues
we'll remove all social gathering limits
we will lift remaining school
requirements
and we'll end health screening before
youth activities which is the only
remaining measure applied to to children
and teenagers
we will also lift the mandatory work
from home order and let me say that's
going to be great news for the downtown
cores in our two big cities as workers
come back to their offices
i know the the there are some
of
some who greet the lifting of
restrictions with some mixed emotions
but i want to remind you
alberta is not alone in this approach
in fact places around the world and
across canada have begun their
transition to the endemic state and have
lifted measures as their omicron wave
subsides and let me just say about that
we keep a close eye on what's happening
right around the world england
ireland
scandinavia several european countries
south africa many u.s states that got
hit
by the omicron wave weeks before
alberta
have also lifted restrictions
and so we can see what impact they've
had and the impact is very encouraging
their numbers and hospitalizations
around the world have continued to
decline
weeks after lifting restrictions so i
think we can move forward
with confidence based on not only our
experience here but around the world
what we're seeing in the areas that uh
are a few weeks ahead of us as i say
including the uk is that the relaxation
of measures is not leading to a rise in
new cases and is not overwhelming
hospitals
this is good news as we move to lift
almost all restrictions in alberta this
week and i'd like to ask all albertans
to be patient with one another as we
transition out of the pandemic mode
we've been in for nearly two years
there will be some who will choose to
wear a mask or who make choices about
their activities based on their own
personal risk assessment and we need to
respect those choices that the choices
that individuals make
i realize it's difficult to shift a
point of view and contemplate the future
when so much of the past two years has
taught us uncertainty
but we just cannot continue
to live our lives indefinitely
with
restrictions on our rights and freedoms
on our normal lives and with all of the
negative consequences that those things
bring for mental health for people's
financial well-being for our life
together as communities we are social
creatures we are designed
to interact with one each other to with
each other to see
each other's faces to
be community to be close to one another
and let us embrace
that normalcy as we are able to lift
these restrictions safely and indeed
with such high rates of vaccination
and more effective new treatments coming
on board
we shouldn't have to be concerned we
will be cautious
and we will continue closely to monitor
trends in the future
but the path forward
will be based on
more and more people choosing the safe
and effective protection of vaccines
as well as a growing number of uh
treatments that are being approved and
will be widely available
so if you are still unvaccinated or not
yet fully vaccinated or haven't yet
gotten around to your booster shot i
just strongly encourage you to do so not
only to ensure that you stay healthy
to but also because it helps us protect
our hospitals from potential future
waves and just a little note on that
uh i know there's a lot of scuttlebutt
out there that the vaccines aren't
really working
well it's true that they're less
effective at preventing
uh infection then earlier because
they've had a waning effect and this
omicron thing is is more transmissible
but they are still incredibly effective
at preventing the kind of severe
outcomes
that land people in hospitals like this
one in grand prairie
so take a look at the information if
you're not there yet and especially for
the folks that got two shots please do
come forward when you're comfortable
doing so for that extra protection of
the booster
now
let me just say that our budget earlier
this week travis's budget was focused on
the future on moving forward
with a particular focus on strengthening
alberta's health care system but also
speeding up our economic recovery and
and just making life better for
albertans in general
we are seizing this moment
and we have to keep moving forward
i believe albertans are ready uh once
again to work together uh for the good
of all of us
this new grand prairie hospital is a
fantastic example of what is possible
when we work together
and i am so honored to mark the grand
official opening of alberta's newest
most modern and technologically advanced
hospital
the hospital officially
opened or practically opened in december
taking over the role as the community's
acute care hospital and emergency
department
from the vital but aging queen elizabeth
ii hospital
the qe2 has served your city for well
over almost 40 years
and will continue to be home for those
in the mackenzie place continuing care
facility as well as to provide dialysis
and rehab and respiratory services for
this community
but grand prairie has grown a lot over
the past four decades
fueled by our energy sector our oil and
gas industry by agriculture and forestry
and so much more in its population is
expected to continue to grow and in fact
a big part of travis's budget
is investing in uh attracting newcomers
from across canada and around the world
for the jobs we think
are we know are being created this year
and next
and so you can expect gp to continue to
welcome a growing population as
communities across the province
now you have needed and deserved a new
hospital here for a very long time and
this government is is delighted to see
this day finally
come to pass
as health minister jason kopping will
explain it in
more detail
this hospital will allow for thousands
more surgeries
it'll provide the best cancer care
available
including for the
first time
radiation therapy to northern alberta
residents the hospital is i and i did
get a an advance advanced tour a few
months back before it began its
functional opening and it is decked out
with the most modern equipment and
services available including the new
connect care with provincial health
information network
projects like this are a part of
alberta's recovery plan part of our
expansion of capacity
this 870 million dollar hospital will
support the health of the community and
provide jobs
social and economic vitality that this
in the city and area
so the recovery plan has sparked so much
growth here the northern petrochemical
corporation planning to build its two
and a half billion dollar facility uh in
greenview county which will create
thousands of jobs and further diversify
the region's economy
the strategic transportation
infrastructure programs investing 32
million dollars in municipal road bridge
and community airport projects across
the province including resource road
improvements in the county of grand
prairie and hello reeve good to see you
we are building alberta's future with
these projects and with the hospital
that can grow
as this wonderful young
and
just tremendous alberta city's growing i
say tremendous city because when i think
they're
that really grand prairie in so many
ways reflects the spirit and the heart
of alberta with the work ethic the youth
of this community
the uh economy based in resources but
also so diversified and leading the way
so this hospital it means more beds
it means more surgeries it means smarter
healthcare services all offered in a
hospital designed around the needs of
families
parents
kids and neighbors
this is your hospital fueled by the
dedication of nurses physicians and
other health care workers to provide you
with the best care that they can
possibly give and alberta is committed
to building a stronger problems a
stronger health care system and more
vibrant communities that can bravely
face uh future emergencies knowing that
we are prepared and resilient
so thank you thank you to everyone thank
you to the construction workers who uh
worked through many cold winter months
here in alberta thank you to all of the
those who who helped to plan this
project thank you especially to grand
prairie residents for your patience well
you know but good things take a while
and and uh and this is a great thing and
so i am
thrilled uh officially to announce the
grand opening of the grand prairie
hospital congratulations